alors muriel vous avez une vidéo vous
avez eu débat on va faire une interview
à peine darde ce que vous préférez en
vous pas de compassion naturelle voilà
j'en ai tout le temps est toujours
quoique si vous ne supportez pas envie
hein quand on nous oblige à ne plus
avoir de compassion pour protéger parce
que ça va trop loin et moi j'y laisse
des plumes quoi votre plus gros coup de
fric à part l'a pas non plus beaucoup de
fric alors celui là
j'aime bien aime bien parce que c'était
il ya un an 80 11 est une marque
enfin c'est une marque lévriers petit
c'est de la charcuterie cerveau comme ça
et plus riches ça s'appelle bâton de
madrid à tort et et m'a sollicité et
c'était un contrat dans 91 moi ça
faisait pas longtemps que je commençais
à est proposée sur une campagne de trois
ans 9 millions de francs et j'ai dit
j'ai besoin de réfléchir et ça m'a pris
une nuit j'ai vu tout ce que je pouvais
je te fuis pensé à ma famille à mes safa
bref à tout ça alors ça c'est celui-là
c'était texto celtics leader c'est bien
le monde moderne c'est surtout que j'ai
dit je ne vais pas le faire parce qu'il
n'ya aucune somme d'argent qui
justifiera tout pendant 5 ans 10 ans 15
ans et des gens une personne 10
personnes qui dans la rue me dise bâton
gage et s'écoute ya pas l'argent mais
trop large et blessures
tu vois votre plus grosse perte
c'est ça dont on va dire que c'est ça
ouais d'accord le mot que vous dites le
plus facilement
merci le mot vous dites le moi
facilement sous le trek sous une très
jolie pas ça c'est sûr ça me fait peur
qu'est ce qui vous fait le plus rire
dans la vie manière les gens qui disent
souvent sous ce qui vous fait le moins
rire ce qui me fait moins rire c'est
qu'on ne trouve pas une réponse à une
question de bien faire et de l'autriche
aujourd'hui il y en a eu beaucoup
certainement mais bien sûr mais je
pensais qu'ils avaient voilà le dernier
mardi c'était long de la dernière régis
lembeye le matin de pierre palmade et
qui m'a dit qu'il allait bien qu'il
avait arrêté avec ses démons et tout ça
en était sorti et qu'ils aient besoin de
me dire qu'il me mais c'est vrai qu'il
avait il m'a écrit comme j'ai 2 bras
gilles muriel dans ma vie ce thème là je
l'attendais depuis 15 ans parce que
bagarre il va pas ce que c'est comme ça
et là la compassion vionnaz mais un
moment j'ai été obligé de la charmeuse
je sers obligé de lâcher ce que je sais
c'est pas possible c'était et ça c'était
un moment et je dis viens enfin
évidemment j'ai si tu peux passer ce
soir il est arrivé à la fin du spectacle
il est monté sur scène non si c'était à
refaire
j'ai vu le père que j'aime l'homme en
revue mercredi
si tu nous regardes
merci pour des fleurs à ses très gentil
le plus mauvais moment de votre vie
maintenant
ouais ce qui vous détend le plus dans la
vie témoin ce qui vous énerve le plus
mais énervement votre plus belle
histoire d'amour
le public de barbarie mais bon comme je
l'appelle et je pensais des personnes
qui ont traversé ma vie c'est pas grave
entendre m comprenez bien que ça c'est
la bonne
voilà c'est comme ça d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'on y met tous
c'est l'histoire d'un mois que la vie
privée et le premier bon coup avec la
plus minable histoire d'amour et pas de
minables de choses minables dans ma vie
thierry je vous remercie madame
messieurs l'endroit où vous rêveriez
d'être en ce moment si vous étiez pas
ici dans mon âme est en train de
regarder cette émission l'endroit vous
détesteriez être en ce moment
l'amour qui nous empêche de dormir
l'amour c'est compliqué ouais ouais
c'est sûr mais c'est en le ventre avec
c'est ce que j'avais vous divisez la
boule là je suis comme souvent vides à
bhl c'est comme c'est génial quelle est
votre lui via leurs souvenirs de cuite
j'étais avec josiane balasko et je me
souviens qu'elle n'était pas bien et moi
je savais qu'elle et moi toujours prévu
nantes
tu viens josette j'ai chanté j'ai dit
c'est pas bien c'est dans ce à quoi je
dis vous me j'ai pas fini de le dire tp
mais je m'étais payer un ensemble un
truc noir dans une marque japonaise
intrus gp s'assimile balle que stark
bois c'était déglingué bons mecs étaient
d'accord avec pal mal tout à l'heure à
montréjeau suis posé la question j'ai
dit
quel est votre pire souvenir de cuite
mais je me souviens pas j'étais bourré
ce que vous avez fait dont vous êtes la
plus fière c'est pas montré de fier
c'est pas très grave à ce truc là mais
je pense que si c'était normal c'est
pour être fiers par exemple de savoir
que je ne suis pas pour rien dans la
construction d'un hôpital à kaboul voilà
mais je suis pas fier je suis contente
mais c'est vrai que vous n'avez pas vous
n'avez pas d'enfants mais vous occuper
quand même des enfants arrivant de
niveau à
pour vous c'est pas qui c'est je vous
dire non au numéro privé est chaud oui
oui qui est bien l'appareil
c'est un mec qui ne manque jamais de
brut avaient trois fois qu'ils
téléphonent faut pas l'appeler sur mon
portable monsieur rappelé rappelle dans
un petit moment il est pas encore là
monsieur merci non il est pas encore là
da kg l'époque c'était pitel ces
magnifiques quoi ce que voilà on a dit
qu'on le ferait on l'a fait trois ans et
demi de 152 salariés au moment où on se
parle peut-être qu'ils sont couchés sur
mais 150 voilà les premiers enfants ont
été opérées on appellerait là-bas à
lesterps on opèrerait % oxygène et c'est
énorme et c'est vrai que c'est pas fier
mais quand je ferme les yeux je ne
regretterai jamais l'avoir quelque chose
comme ça a fait savoir qu'il ya
peut-être un moment à l'enfant qui est
sauvé et que j'allais dire pricipaux
quelque chose je veux pas le dire qu'un
enfant qui est sauvé voilà en fait ça
avec deux loges pour le sort de la lch
professeur deloche eric cheysson et
c'est pour ça que j'apporte heathcliff
tirer avec alain deloche c'est des mecs
ça nous mène à la caméra sur nous faire
voilà alors l'un de leurs chevaux la
grille il a écrit un bouquin il parle de
son métier sa trajectoire
on est en direct les commissions de pair
avec la lys a ensuite on va faire un
film avec sa presse
c'est magnifique c'est que de l'humanité
que de l'amour que des belles choses
donc je dis enfin que les fonds blancs à
l'aide de l'os
le héros vous préférez robin des bois le
héros vous détestez les princes
charmants
c'est grave quoi qu'est ce qu'on paye
cher tout non celui là je gère pays le
plus grand acteur du monde pour vous
rien et un wii et le plus nul bague il
est tellement nul qui se recueillent que
je peux dire son nom ne soit même pas
que c'était la plus grande actrice du
monde
je crois que c'est moi et l'actrice la
vie nul du monde elle alors elle est
mariée avec la plante pullulent et ça
fait un bon dîner
ce calcul sexy en vo muriel c'est
difficile cette question devrait
peut-être là c'est dire est que
peut-être c'est mon ambiguïté peut-être
votre bouche comme ça est tout petit et
un peu ce que j'aime bien c'est beau la
mer
ce qu'il ya de moins sexy en vo muriel
le test yann moix sexy ccc pense qu'on
n'a pas que donne pas cette ambiguïté je
sais pas je m'en bourg je sais pas c'est
moins sexy
le plus direct ce que vous préférez dans
le sec alors dans le sait que j'aime
beaucoup la partie qui affamant est-ce
que vous dégoûte dans le choix est là
particulier avec aussi
secours devaient baisser pendant la
mission